long have you been married now I think
25 years and you met your life in
Bahrain right I was on a deployment in
the Navy and we didn't know anything
about Bahrain we didn't know what was
going on there because there's again
there's no internet there's no going to
some random place in the desert and then
when we finally flew to Bahrain Squad 2
was waiting for us they were saying hey
this place is like there's good times to
be had there's bars and girls and the
whole nine yards yeah we went to a bar
one of my friends in Squad two had said
to me oh there's these two girls I know
you're gonna talk to them and sure
enough walked in this bar and I saw a
tall beautiful blonde woman I walked up
to her and I said in like a Jim Carrey
tone should I just call you Aphrodite's
goddess of love and she looked at me
like I was an idiot which was accurate
and then you know I bought her a drink
and the rest as they say is history